hey Carlos good to see you how are you
both doing good great can't complain
I like it you went with the matching red
tops it's good what come on that's red
from here it's red okay this movie is
like the perfect film to cuddle up with
someone and watch what you guys describe
for me what is the perfect scenario what
do you need to set up how do you need to
set up your living room or your dental
watching this movie darkness yeah like
really want to be enveloped yeah turn
off all the lights turn off your phone
so that you can pay attention you don't
miss anything there's a lot that happens
but definitely like darkness maybe open
a window so it's a little bit of a drag
or little chocolate like sprinkle in it
you know like a little like new Arden
Rita in salty combo it's all about sweet
and salty yeah I like the specificity
there you guys very good but when you
get to work so closely with someone on a
project because it's a lot of this is
just a two of you what do you learn
about the other person Camila what have
you learned about Jessie something you
can share
no Carlos the main thing being that
Jessie is so bad at talk no no I've
learned Jessie's amazing to work with
truly like we had such a great time he's
very positive attitude on set
he's a can-do kind of guy which is I
mean you never know that you can meet
someone and think that they're super
cool but you have no idea what they're
like on set and I was very relieved to
know how great he was to work with and
also that he has an amazing relationship
with a sister who is also an amazing
human being who was around a lot and
I really enjoy both of your companies oh
listen I can sing praises about Camille
all day her professionalism and her
skillfulness and things like that but
what was really important something I
discovered myself is that Camille and I
have the same taste in junk food so like
our Starbucks coffees our McDonald's
fries and things like that I think
that's really what bonded us it was the
junk food like it was the you know the
ramen oh my gosh you blew my mind with
that ramen I try to tell you those
things that matter you know when it
comes yeah those are things that really
make a difference yeah I mean if you
can't bond on ramen how can you get
along on set how are you with each other
if you don't know that you like the same
ramen I think down on anyone who doesn't
like ramen that I like I honestly do
it's not it's not something I want to do
I just I do it instantly um how are you
guys doing in this time right now are
you are you missing your respective cast
mates from your shows are you guys
keeping in touch with them over all this
like a zoom and Skype and all this
technology everybody's using right now
yeah I think I definitely miss my cast
and it's funny how I almost feel like
I'm seeing them just as much if not more
now during 14 there's so many face times
and keeping each other updated I think
usually when we're filming we see each
other and set but it's hard to see each
other off-site because so many of us
have different things going on over we
over the weekend so now I feel like
we're all really getting the time to
catch up
cool cool yeah that's cool yeah I stayed
in contact with my cast and the boys
quite a bit during this I mean we have a
pretty frequently used group chat that's
been amplified now so I actually put it
on do not disturb who they talk too much
but like you say I feel like we all talk
more now than we did you know especially
during the season like during the season
I almost never see them all of our
shooting schedules are opposite yeah but
now we seem to be more in touch than we
were before
well guys thank you so much for your
time I gotta I gotta wrap this up I
gotta go but this has been so much fun
and thank you for the movie - it's it's
a blast well of course yeah glad you
like this thanks Carlos